j'ai exploré mars n'est pas l'air très
convaincu en fait c'est parce que je
ressemble pas matt damon voit la preuve
par l'image
en 2012 j'ai participé à une simulation
d'exploration martienne dans le désert
de l'utah
alors comment j'en suis venu là j'ai
fait une thèse en sciences de gestion
c'est moins impressionnant c'est ça donc
pendant quinze jours j'ai participé à
une simulation dans le désert dans une
capsule de 20 m² au sein d'un équipage
de six personnes et cette capsule de 20
m² c'était un petit peu mon laboratoire
pour observer le quotidien de l'équipage
alors qu'est ce que c'est une simulation
d'exploration martienne est bien de
simulation c'est une situation
d'apprentissage on simule pour apprendre
qu est ce qui vous vient à l'esprit
lorsque vous pensez à l'exploration
martienne rapidement moi je pourrais
dire la science la technologie et puis
quelque chose peut-être de relatif à
l'aventuré humaine en la science
pourquoi la science parce que je peux
pas envisager qu'on envoie six personnes
pendant deux ans pour aller sur mars à
plus de 250 millions de kilomètres pour
aller faire un safari photo la
technologie parce que il nous faut une
technologie pour aller sur mars
basiquement fait nouveau je vais aller
spatiale une capsule quelque chose de
fiable en fait un qui tienne pour aller
sur mars
celle aventure humaine je sais pas pour
vous c'est quoi un explorateur de mars
moi ce qui me vient à l'esprit c'est
quelqu'un qui est peut-être pas un super
héros mais un héros au moins quelqu'un
d'assez fort qui a été préparé pendant
très très longtemps qu'elle est capable
de résister à une pression très
importante au stress
c'est quelqu'un qui est capable de vivre
finalement dans des conditions qui sont
totalement extraordinaire extrême
hostile en bref d'exploration martienne
c'est faire face à l'inconnu et c'est
vivre une expérience extraordinaire
moi j'ai l'impression qu'avec ces trois
éléments là je retrouve pas tout ce que
j'ai vécu au sein de cette mission de
simulation
lorsque je voudrais faire si vous
partagez mon expérience et vous raconter
une histoire et qu'on recherche ensemble
les éléments qui manquent
alors d'abord on va planter le décor ya
une capsule en plein milieu du désert de
l'utah qu'on appelle la mdrs qui
appartient la mars society qui est une
association indépendante qui se donne
pour objectif d'aller explorer mars mais
aussi d'implanter les humains sur mars
elle considère que la capsule qu'on
appelle aussi le web comme un
laboratoire pour apprendre à travailler
et vivre ensemble sur une autre planète
moi ce qui frappe en premier ce qui m'a
frappé franchement quand je suis arrivé
dans l'utah c'est le paysage
c'est un paysage totalement martien on
est en immersion totale dans le paysage
moi c'est pas la capsule qui est qui m'a
frappé au départ c'est vraiment le les
roches les couleurs ocre rouge la forme
des roches et ça c'est un élément qui
est très important pour faire comme si
on était sur mars
il n'y a pas de traces d'activités
humaines un paysage à perte de vue
ensuite il isolement la capsule aller en
plein milieu du désert
alors c'est un isolement qui est un peu
relative parce qu'à 25 km quand même une
station service
il ya aussi le shérif du coin il
s'appelle dj jusqu'au phare c'est
quelqu'un qui nous apporte de l'eau
parce qu'un rationnement en fait on doit
vivre en autonomie pendant quinze jours
donc un rationnement d'eau donc nous
amène un peu d'eau si on a un problème
il vient si vraiment on a un problème le
but en effet vous l'avez compris c'est
de vivre en autonomie pendant quinze
jours
alors ça suppose des règles de conduite
on va dire des pratiques de simulation
et ces règles par exemple basse et si
vous voulez sortir
vous devez enfilé une combinaison
spatiale mais je repasse cave rôle
presque parce que c'est en fait si vous
allez sur mars
c'est un peu ce que vous allez faire
ensuite si vous voulez sortir avec votre
combinaison spatiale vous devez simuler
le changement de pression entre
l'intérieur et l'extérieur de la station
donc vous restait cinq minutes à
l'intérieur d'un sas bienvenue à bord
c'est un petit meublé de 20 m² pour 6
personnes et c'est à la fois un lieu
dans lequel vous vivez
au sens ordinaire est un lieu dans
lequel vous travaillez vous avez une
table de travail
vous avez une petite cuisine un autre
plan de travail une télé une
bibliothèque quelques bouquins donc
c'est pas mal vous êtes dans un lieu où
évidemment il ya un certain confinement
à 6 la pression peut monter assez
rapidement au sein du collectif au sein
de l'équipage mais vous avez la chance
d'avoir une petite couche est
individuelle donc derrière moi il ya six
couchettes individuel avec une porte qui
ferme c'est incroyable pourquoi je
rentre dans ma petite fourchette
voilà je viens gens d'abord je suis chez
moi là je suis dans mon refuge je tue
bien là je me sens bien et puis je me
dis bah tiens je vais aller au boulot je
vais travailler up et je suis à la table
de travail
c'est quand même incroyable là il n'y a
aucune excuse à pour arriver en retard
donc le coup moi j'ai appris des choses
par rapport à sa fin et comme
inconvénient moi je verrais bien
imaginer nous avons envie vraiment
d'être seul ou vous êtes anglais
quinquin enfin une petite tension puis
vous voulez vous isolez ça va être
compliqué ça va être très compliqué si
vous respectez les règles de la
simulation
vous ne pouvez pas sortir vous pouvez
pas vous dire bon allez je vais faire un
tour en fait non les gens qui vont
explorer mars ils vont pas dire ça donc
vous vous respectez les règles
d'utilisation
je vous parle est un petit peu de
l'équipage ont ce qu'il faut dire sur
l'équipage
donc c'est un équipage de six personnes
on a tous un projet scientifique et à
côté de ce projet scientifique
on a une fonction dans la station alors
une fonction ça peut être par exemple
ingénieur de bord
c'est quelque chose de cassé je vais
réparer je vais vérifier les différents
niveaux les ressources l'eau enfin voila
si tout va bien je peux être
responsables de la sécurité et de la
santé de l'équipage
il ya aussi deux rôle hiérarchique
alors là il ya l'art à vouvoyer lara les
chefs de mission et à les biologistes
donc elle fait un projet de recherche en
biologie mais elle est la chef de
mission notre équipage il ya karina qui
elle est dans la recherche biomédicale
elle est responsable de la sécurité à la
santé et au les informaticiens
ingénieurs au bord chemin astrophysicien
et l'ingénieur de bord également robert
tu les as de quoi vous et moi je suis le
second donc le second c'est celui en
fait qui est là lorsque le chef n'est
pas là et je fais ma ma recherche en
sciences de gestion
et je me suis aperçu en fait qui avait
beaucoup d'attentes différente par
rapport à cette mission il ya des gens
qui faisaient pour explorer mars aller
faire du quad en crosse ou l'autre
apprendre à vivre en environnement
extrême faire l'expérience du complément
apprendre à vivre dans un petit monde
et puis à des gens qui étaient là pour
faire de la science la question j'ai
envie de poser c'est est ce qu'on peut
apprendre à vivre et à travailler
ensemble sans avoir l'objectif comme ces
énigmes moi je n'ai pas la réponse
pendant la première semaine la première
chose que à part la beauté du paysage
il fait froid la station est pas très
bien isolé au plan thermique elle n'est
pas isolé non plus au niveau de la
poussière on est en plein milieu du
désert
moi je me souviens beaucoup de cette
poussière là par exemple il y avait et
dans le monde poussière y compris du
sable dans mon duvet donc quand je
rentrais chez moi je rentre dans mon
univers
il y avait un petit peu une partie du
désert qui était avec moi et puis
pendant cette première semaine
il ya quelques tensions après minute qui
éclate au sein de l'équipage
la première chose qu'on apprend
au bout de deux jours s'est pas réalisé
un projet scientifique
c'est à vivre ensemble la première chose
à laquelle on est confrontés ou deux
trois jours c'est pas le fait qu'on
arrive d'institutions prestigieuses la
fierté d'avoir été sélectionné par la
mars society
non non c'est à vivre ensemble au
quotidien
pendant la deuxième semaine mais tension
disparaissent progressivement jusqu'à la
fin de la mission des sentiments alors
je sais pas si c'est un sentiment
partagé par le collectif par l'équipage
mais moi je le sentiment d'une mission
accomplie je vais vous montrer quelques
éléments quelques traces de notre
activité pendant la simulation qui me
semblent commencer à répondre à l'entrée
à apporter les éléments c'est les
activités ordinaires domestique par
exemple faire un calendrier de rotation
pour les tâches ménagères
c'est pas quelque chose qui est propre à
l'exploration spatiale je pense que si
vous avez fait un peu de colocation vous
devez savoir que le premier élément
l'élément critique c'est le ménage la
convivialité
il faut partager ce moment là ensemble
il ne faut pas s'exclure du fait
partager un repas un petit déjeuner la
gymnastique pas faire des gestes tout à
fait ridicule tous les matins avec un
espace qui n'est pas vraiment approprié
pour mais le faire quand même et inventé
des figures faire des choses voilà
s'amuser ensemble passer un bon moment
le beurre de cacahuète les états unis
mais pas que alors moi j'aime pas le
port de cacahuètes par exemple comment
ça se fait que j'ai trouvé là c'est le
meilleur beurre de cacahuète faut jamais
mangé de ma vie il fallait vraiment que
j'aille dans une mission de simulation
d'exploration martienne pour apprécier
une part de cacahuètes explorer mars
c'est aussi explorer la vie quotidienne
parce que la question c'est qu'est ce
qu'on peut faire de sa pa deux
orientations
d'abord pour l'exploration spatiale
science technology aventure humaine je
suis d'accord le fait que les
explorateurs de mars ont aussi une vie
ordinaire pendant deux ans de mission
c'est pas anodin c'est pas trivial
ce n'est pas banal ce que j'espère c'est
que les agences spatiales ne prendront
pas conscience de ça deux jours avant
d'envoyer six personnes pendant deux ans
à 250 millions 2,4 m deuxième
orientation
si je vous disais que d'aller sur mars
peut nous apprendre à vivre sur terre
ici là dans nos capsules pas que la
capsule de l'utah toutes nos capsules
est ce que ces capsules là ne sont pas
des laboratoires pour apprendre à vivre
ensemble
est ce que nous n'avons pas déjà tous
marcher sur mars
je vous remercie